the polls are open throughout most of
Afghanistan this morning as voters cast
ballots in today's parliamentary
elections but the voting is overshadowed
by security concerns after this week's
deadly ambush attack on a police chief
in Kandahar Charlie d'Agata is in Kabul
the capital Charlie good morning well
good morning already here in Kabul there
been multiple explosions including
homemade bombs even mortars dozens of
people have been taken to the hospital
including one child who's pronounced
dead on arrival the Interior Minister
boosted the number of security forces
from 50,000 to 70,000 but there have
been some technical glitches that have
meant that some voting will be carried
over into tomorrow now the Taliban have
made repeated threats to attack security
forces and to shut down roads leading to
these polling stations yet it appears
that Afghans by the millions are turning
out to vote at least where they can some
2,000 polling stations were closed down
before voting even started now this is
how much it matters to the United States
America's top commander here general
Scott Miller took to the streets of
Kabul yesterday this is after an
assassination of a top Afghan commander
where the general had to pull his own
sidearm the general told Afghans they
should be proud of their security forces
and urged them to get out and vote
ultimately the results of this vote may
matter less than the number of people
who decided to take part in it Anthony
Charlie d'Agata reporting from Kabul
this morning Thank You charlie